Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill burn his time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
Monday,
December 4th,
2000 and fucking
17.
Yeah,
there we go.
I just realized I just gave a fuck and just gave dean Delray a check and I wrote
December 5th on it.
I thought tomorrow was December 5th.
Well it is by the time you hear this,
but I did the Sunday night.
NAF.
Fuck it.
Tell him not to deposit the check.
Well they can.
You can still deposit it right?
And then they don't fucking whatever a del Ray opened for me this weekend.
Holy Shit.
We got the levels up too high here.
They are too high.
I can't hear myself thinking here.
For God sakes.
Could you just shut it down please.
Thank you.
Um,
dude,
I'm fucking sitting there wanting to,
and I'm sitting there minding my own business in my house,
my fucking house.
Fuck you bankers.
It's mine now until I die.
Then you get it back.
Don't you get cuts?
Um,
they just sit there waiting.
It would pay off your house.
Look out your window.
There'll be a banker sitting out there like a fucking,
like a Goddamn vulture waiting for you to fucking,
I'll get,
let them looking at me eating bacon.
I guess Bacon's good for you now.
I don't know what the fuck.
I don't know what I know what I'm talking about.
Um,
anyways,
um,
I wonder what room I'm going to die in this house here.
But think about that when you just get the house,
like I'm not fucking leaving.
I'm staying here.
Right.
And then you just,
when you,
once you make that decision,
you're like,
well then I'm going to fucking die in here.
What room is it going to be?
I think a lot of people die at breakfast nooks.
You know,
just sitting down and having some toast.
Read the morning paper.
That wouldn't be a bad way to go.
Let's go face down until like fucking half piece of grapefruit.
But
what were on would you want to die in?
You don't want to do it in the shower,
right?
That's fucking awful.
And you're all waterlogged,
you know,
Bang your head on.
The fucking lot of people die in the shower.
They slip and fall,
you know,
and they can't get up right.
And that's why they came out with dead fucking that thing there for all the old
people.
But what a lot of people don't realize is a lot of them fall in the fucking
shower and then they go to use their little,
I've fallen and I can't get up thing and then they get electrocuted.
I don't think that happens,
but I would be worried about that.
Trying to drag my old prude ass out of the fucking tub.
Oh my God.
That's gotta be the worst when he gets so old.
You're afraid to take a shower.
You got to bring like a fucking lazy boy.
Oh Shit.
I'm sorry.
They just fucking struck me.
He's funny.
He just got a giant lazy,
we got a recliner in your shower.
It's an hour.
It's waterproof.
I don't know the fuck you.
I liked.
I loved that flashlight that just came out that that runs on water.
I mean,
giving you,
what are we doing?
What the fuck are we doing in the Middle East?
Jesus Christ.
Just put that in a fucking car.
Stick 20 olds flashlights in the car,
I'll drive slower.
It's just get out of there already,
right?
The fuck we think we're doing.
You know what?
Fuck.
The Middle East is like,
my lease is like ear a civilian and you get in the middle of like a domestic
violence fucking incident,
you know,
and you try to break it up,
and the second he'd go to break it up,
the woman starts beating on you and get off my abusive husband.
That's what it's like over there.
Just fucking get those water flashlights.
This is what you do.
You get those water flashlights and you put them into fucking Scotus that
everybody has to ride his scooter,
whether you're fat or old or whatever.
You got to ride one in cars or illegal.
All right?
The amount of people wipe it out and dying bride,
it frees up the fucking traffic.
We're not using as much oil and then they go bankrupt over there.
How about that there?
Did I solve the Middle Eastern Obama's don't we do that every week?
Every week?
I'm gonna have a new fucking solution for the Middle East.
Um,
anyway,
I don't want the fuck I'm talking about.
I just,
can you imagine just having a giant fucking recliner,
you know,
and then you have like debt,
little grabby thing and you just turn on the fucking water.
What are those grabby things?
You know,
you fucking,
you,
you pull the handle and then you got an x,
like the fucking groceries.
They always grab like a can of soup or some shit.
Yeah.
What breeding from Broccoli whenever they go up there and they fucking Yank it
down.
I don't know that,
that doesn't happen anymore.
There's no,
there's no regular person running a fucking grocery store anymore.
Is there?
Yeah.
Grocery stores are fucking weird man.
Dot.
They could kind of like the food version of a casino.
Like you just feel like there's somebody up in the ceiling watching you buying
like a two way mirror when you go in there,
it's really nothing stopped.
But yeah,
I mean one time I walked into this grocery store with Patrice and we acted like
fucking children.
He got me going like,
he was so fucking silly.
I'm at one time,
he just goes,
uh,
we were going and he was staying at my apartment for pilot season.
Both of us creeps trying to get on must see TV.
Yeah.
How do you think that worked out?
So,
um,
we were in like Ralph's or some shit and he just kept going a pill.
You want some of these?
And when he would go to point at it,
he would like,
he'd have his hand way too close to the bag and he was like bread or something.
He goes,
Bill,
you need some of this.
And he was,
he would just push his finger into like fucking three slices of bread through
the rapper.
And he just started doing that around the grocery store and I was fucking
crying,
laughing.
He did it.
The cookies he was doing,
he was doing it to fruit and these giant fucking fingers,
they bill you.
Why?
One of the easy,
just like all the way through the fucking thing and I'm immature is fuck.
And it was just making me fucking cry,
laugh.
And he's a comedian so he just kept doing it.
And I was trying to do it.
I could even,
you know,
my fingers weren't,
I don't know.
I was laughing too hard.
I couldn't fucking do it as good as him.
Um,
anyways,
Jesus.
I hadn't thought about that for fucking ever and I want to apologize.
Maybe it wasn't Ralph's.
What the fuck?
Where are we?
I always hated rouse,
you know,
it's just a fucking pain in the ass.
The one that was down the street.
I used to live off as sunset and it was a Ralphs.
They used to be called rock and roll.
Ralph's.
Everything was rock and roll.
Denny's rock and roll.
Ralph's steps back like leftover from the hair metal shit.
You know the rock and roll Hyatt right next to fucking the comedy storm.
John Bonham used to ride motorcycles.
There's some shit into the fucking thing.
I don't know what.
MMM,
I have no idea.
I don't know what the fuck it was.
I even know where we were at.
Um,
okay.
Jesus Christ.
I have decided that in Fred.
What the fuck was they talking about?
It's talking about being an old man,
but there were cleaner and a God damn shower,
whatever that moment is come and gone.
That's what happens on the podcast.
I just fucking talk and whatever happens,
it happens.
By the way,
I would like to thank everybody that came out to Albuquerque,
New Mexico.
I had a great fucking time at route 66 casino.
That's the second time I played there.
I fucking love that place to crab was awesome.
And then the next,
uh,
the next last night I played in Tucson,
Arizona.
Another great time.
Just fucking great people,
great parts of the country,
uh,
fun fucking crowds.
And um,
I got to tell you that I'm acting like a fucking idiot on stage.
Like yet.
I think it's my reaction to this fucking,
this,
this weird fog that is starting to roll in slowly rolling in over the last five
years on standup comedy where all of a sudden I sit there on stage and sometimes
I think after I say something like,
did somebody record that?
Am I going to get into trouble?
I even thought,
I never thought that the first fucking 20 years of my career in the last five
years,
it just keeps creeping into my head.
And in order to beat it down,
I,
okay.
I Dunno.
I think I'm going a little harder.
Somebody scared.
There's gotta be some sort of pushback on this fucking vibe that's out there,
that everything is so God damn serious.
Now Jesus fucking Christ.
Couple guys want to be women.
A couple of guys take their dicks out at work and then all of a sudden
everybody's got to look.
Whew.
How did he mean that joke?
Is that a joke or is that legislation for a new law?
Like this whole fucking vibe that's out there.
It's,
it's,
it's really weird
and fucking young people are acting like old people.
Okay.
You know?
And I think that's because they're on social media and all that shit and they're
just watching this stuff.
24 seven.
It's like fucking,
I dunno.
Okay.
It's fucking up their brains,
man.
C'Mon millennials could get,
got to do something that spoil you.
Supposed to make me uncomfortable.
Origin,
mural,
jack crunch.
Why?
And I go and,
you know,
yeah,
I guess they have that new documentary,
Meth town on fucking,
uh,
Hbo d Delray told me to wash it.
I can't fucking watch that shit.
I'm not going to watch a bunch of toothless fucking pee.
But those God damn people,
I swear to God,
they look like they're from the 18 hundreds.
So bad.
They fucked their faces up with that meth shit.
I'll tell you,
once you lose your fucking teeth,
he,
you look like you're 80.
I don't care how old you are.
You could take one of those gorgeous Victoria secret models.
They,
if they don't have any fucking teeth and they didn't get a partial or a fucking
implant or whatever the fuck you call them
dentures as some shit.
If you just walk around toothless,
you immediately look,
you look like homer Simpson's fucking that guy that falls asleep.
His Dad is it his dad?
Um,
their grandfather,
right?
I don't know.
Yeah.
So I had that on.
I was talking to someone on the phone and,
and dean kept telling me,
what you got to see it,
dude,
you got to see.
And even dean said,
man,
I fucking shut this thing off like three times.
He goes,
it's fucking brutal.
So I just had the sound down and I was watching all these toothless fucking
people with these crazy looks on their faces.
And uh,
I was on the phone and at one point I just saw somebody kicking dog shit like
piles of dog shit,
different piles all around the house,
like hoarding dog shit out of the way in this person's house with newspaper all
over it and stuff.
And um,
that's when I turned the channel.
I don't know about you guys,
but I drew the line at the,
uh,
I drew the line at the dog.
Shit,
there's a few things that make me turn the channel.
Okay.
Drug addicts would dog shit in their house and,
and strong female characters make me turn the channel.
And not because I have anything against a strong female character.
It's just that they don't develop them.
I think everybody in Hollywood is so afraid of getting yelled at by these
women's groups that they just throw in these strong female characters,
but they don't,
they don't make a three dimensional character.
They just have a woman yelling at guys and grabbing them by their fucking lapels
of this suit and throw them over couches and shit.
It's like they took like leftovers,
Steven Seagal Shit,
and the guy will give it to the woman here.
See she Straub all of a sudden every fucking gia dick and balls
to psych with this fucking Parson sky outweighs it by like a fucking hundred
pounds.
What am I,
what am I watching?
I want you to it.
Recently,
I might even say the fucking show,
but I'm watching this guy,
this guy's like 40 fucking years old.
He's talking to a 19 year old redneck woman who lives to a fucking lake in the
middle of the Arkansas and she's having a battle of wits with them and she's
winning my Jesus fucking Christ.
The Fun.
What kind of a fucking 19 year old can beat a fucking 50 year old guy in a
battle of wits.
And wants to talking about fucking Nintendo or whatever.
The fucking kids playing in the tendo.
Sorry.
Whenever you guys play.
Um,
I'm not a Gamer.
All right.
I used to be a booze hound.
I'm still not drinking the fuck is it?
It's a one of my a hundred and some days in at this point.
It's one oh five days,
three days.
Anna.
It's one oh eight.
We went oh nine by the time he listened to this thing.
But I gotta tell you I'm fucking,
I'm getting weak.
I'm getting a week or the holidays,
a role in it.
I think I'll be good through December,
but uh,
I'm going to the fucking Rosebowl again this year.
This is my 10th Rose Ball.
All right.
It's the 10 anniversary for me and Joe Barton.
Nick the originals,
the original fucking drunk maniacs at that game.
And what's so fucking awesome now about the college football playoff is that
every three years now,
the Rose Bowl is a playoff game.
Last time it was a Florida state and Oregon,
I believe,
a Jamison Winston.
And,
uh,
the guy from fucking a Tennessee,
Tyson's,
I can't remember his name.
Mary Yoda.
Is that the coach?
I don't know what the fuck the guy from Oregon,
he's great,
right?
Um,
and this year it's going to be the Oklahoma sooners versus the fucking,
uh,
who else got in?
Let's see.
It's clubs in verse Alabama and then we got a fucking Oklahoma's playing hope.
Nobody in the big 10 got in
Tcu got their fucking asses kicked.
I mean,
and whenever I watched Tcu they went,
I can't believe I fucking miss that.
Who the fuck is Oklahoma plate?
Yeah.
Wasn't Wisconsin.
Clemson is Alabama.
I got to hit pause here.
This is going to turn out.
Fuck that.
You guys can listen how dumb I am.
I know this.
USC didn't get in.
It's gotta be a conference.
Fucking champion Miami laws to Clemson.
Auburn didn't get in.
Who the fuck is it?
Okay,
I got to hit pause.
I don't know the fuck it is.
I'm an asshole.
Georgia.
I actually didn't look it up.
I just sat there and I fucking started thinking like,
what the fuck else is in there?
Miami,
central Florida,
Florida state,
South Carolina,
gators,
Georgia.
That's how I did it.
Started down,
I always start down in Miami and I fucking work my way up the George
[inaudible],
Georgia bulldogs.
And I know there's a lot of people were upset.
A lot of people were upset that a,
it's such a flawed fucking system.
Um,
I know Jay lie head was telling me that fucking Alabama didn't play anybody,
so I didn't even fucking play anybody.
And then I'm thinking like,
well,
the big 10 wasn't his fucking,
you know,
Wisconsin being undefeated is amazing until you fucking look at the,
yeah,
the western side of the fucking big 10 Nebraska stinks.
Illinois was pathetic.
Indiana stakes,
Minnesota stakes.
Northwestern was decent.
They were seven and two,
but I mean,
if you won that last seven games,
what they played,
nobody.
Um,
and I are sitting there going like,
so I'm like,
what the fuck is he talking about?
You know,
it's like you guys lost a fucking Iowa.
I was,
I was halfway decent.
Penn state was overrated.
What the fuck you talking about?
So,
you know what I did?
I actually listened to Jay law head and I looked up the fucking Alabama crimson
tide is fucking schedule and I gotta tell you,
I think I could've got them five fucking winds.
J Law head,
sorry.
J Law had I owe an apology to this is who they played.
Florida state.
Who stinks then they played Colorado state at,
I don't even know what they,
those fucking people should be selling insurance out there.
Get rid of that football team.
Mississippi.
They stink this year.
Arkansas stunk this year.
Lsu,
you know Lee came on late,
but they stink.
I love them.
Mercer.
Is that a woman's college?
I didn't know who the fuck that is.
Fresno state.
I went to that game.
Fresno state,
you know,
I'd say they stink,
but I've watched too many of those behind the scenes.
Things about frago Fresno real cobalt,
the cap.
We are so I'm not gonna say shit about Fresno.
I'm just saying,
you know,
they could have been a little better.
Vanderbilt a too fucking smart to be good.
Texas a and M,
they stunk.
Tennessee fucking stanks Mississippi state was decent.
Then they played Auburn who was a good fucking team and they lost.
However they did beat the shit out of people.
They want 24,
740120360 six to three 41 to nine.
They did beat the fuck out of people.
56 to nothing against a woman's college.
41 at 10 59 and nothing against Vanderbilt.
Does he play a bunch of fucking architects?
Uh,
Nate Barr Godsy was starting at fucking punter 27,
19 against Texas a and m 45 seven.
Hey,
by the way,
all those students that fuck that guy out of that fucking head coaching job at
Tennessee were those signs that they wrote,
was that true?
And how?
Cause they really fucking,
I dunno man.
I hope they did some research this whole fucking trial by Internet.
Um,
I left to look that up mad cause that just,
I was like fucking in the,
some of the shit that people wrote on sides.
He was at Penn state.
I don't know during the whole time or part of the time when that sent Dusky guy
was there,
but it's just like,
you know,
okay,
it's,
I don't understand this stuff.
I love how there's like one guy does some shit,
then all of a sudden like the most horrific fucking thing you could do a
basically and then all of a sudden everybody fucking knew and nobody said
anything.
Everybody,
everybody.
I'm not saying they weren't a few people like,
oh Jesus,
we've got to fucking protect the university,
but just anybody who was there as automatically fucking guilty.
Some of these fucking kids,
man.
I,
you know,
this whole trial by fucking social media is a little out of control there.
But anyways,
so I'm going off the rails here.
Um,
okay.
So I dunno.
We'll see.
We'll see what the fuck happens.
Uh,
I know Jay was upset that Ohio state did get in.
I,
you got to tell you I'll have stayed at a tougher schedule than fucking Alabama.
Easily,
easily had a tougher fucking schedule.
But what about,
what about Auburn?
What about Auburn man,
they beat Georgia when they were number one.
Then they beat Alabama.
They,
they be too fucking number once.
Then they had to go back and beat fucking George again.
They couldn't do it.
You know what happened with that?
That fucking Auburn's coach opened his big fat fucking mouth.
We kicked a dog crap out of them,
did we?
We don't kick the dog crap out of them dead.
You know what I mean?
I hope every fucking person who's in sports journalism,
I hope they watched that.
They see that fucking clip and then you see the fucking Georgia bulldog showing
up the next game with flames coming out of their fucking nostrils.
You know,
the next time you're going to sit there and trash bill Belicheck and say he's
quote unquote was so boring and his press conferences,
that's because the man is a genius bill.
Bella check is never going to be like,
we kicked the dog crap out.
Modern work
character fuckin dog crap on the boom.
Why the fuck would you say that?
You know,
it says that the kind of guy who wears a fucking golf and hand when he's
coaching a football team,
um,
what a dumb fucking think that that is the stupidest fucking thing you can do.
Okay.
Bebo when the fucking cowboys will fucking kicking the shit out of the Steelers
and like Superbowl nine or 10,
I dunno,
about 40 years ago,
you have a look at those highlights and fucking Roy GRL a missed that field goal
and stupid as cliff Harris got in his face,
patted him on the fucking helmet and then Lambert came over and just body
slammed cliff Harris back when you could do that and there wasn't a fucking,
you know,
a bunch of fines and you had to go fucking sing acapella to some fuck a woman's
group.
Whatever the fucking punishment is now.
Right.
You could do that.
That turned the tide of the game.
Keep your fucking mouth shut until you're holding the championship trophy and
then you don't need to talk shit cause you want it.
You're fucking Ugh,
we don't kick the dog crap out of them.
What happened?
She played him a few weeks later.
You get the old right there,
Fred,
don't you?
Um,
so anyways,
so it was a lot of 'em.
Okay.
There was a lot of uh,
um,
I was 100% wrong.
I thought j Lo head was just being a fucking homer.
He was absolutely fucking right.
Alabama didn't play anybody,
but they scored a lot of fucking points.
Who knows?
We'll see.
We'll see it now.
If Alabama goes in and wins the whole fucking thing,
then what does that do?
I actually like how vague this is and how many arguments that it creates.
Just the whole fuck,
you know?
And at the end of the day,
you can't,
you can't open this up to some giant fucking march madness.
The game is just simply to fucking violent.
I love that it's four teams and I love that people get left out,
you know,
the same way.
I love seeing a little kid crying because his mother wouldn't get him the toy
that he wanted.
That just warms my heart whenever I see that.
And he'd seen a little spoiled Brat like,
yeah,
fuck you.
And gave you a cheerios this morning,
didn't you?
Didn't I,
you know,
meanwhile I'm going to spoil a shit on and my daughter,
I'm all over the map here and what the fuck I'm talking about.
Um,
so that's what I did all day.
Uh,
all day on fry out Friday and Saturday.
I just watched fucking college football other than when I was traveling,
going out to a,
the fact that I fly out to
Albuquerque,
New Mexico,
and he was funny.
It was a six hour drive from Albuquerque to Tucson.
I should have done that.
I wasn't paying attention.
I actually flew down and rather than getting a direct flight,
I had to connect through Phoenix.
So it was the fire.
I could have flown from La to,
to the Goddamn Columbus,
Ohio,
you know,
and uh,
speaking of buckeyes right in that,
the amount of time that it took me in this,
the fucking person who flew us from Phoenix,
from,
from uh,
Albuquerque to Phoenix.
Okay.
We're taxiing out to get to the,
uh,
I don't know,
on our way out to the runway.
Right.
And the guide bags a left and then quickly goes back to the right.
And I was just like,
Whoa,
what the fuck?
And I was like,
well,
you know,
maybe it was the tower.
Maybe they said make a left on a Bravo Radha.
I mean,
right.
Sorry.
Right.
Correction,
go right on.
Bravo.
Right.
So I got this app work and listen to the tower.
So I put it on to here to try and listen to see if I could hear anything,
which I couldn't.
So we take off flights,
great flying,
everything's fine.
Not No fucking problems would come in and go land,
land.
Landing was nice and everything.
And then we're going in with taxing me in.
We go in to get into the a where you parked the plane,
whatever the fuck he call it,
the gate.
And this fucking guy,
he literally did a donut.
He did a three 60 with the airplane.
He once again went left when he was supposed to go.
Right.
And we fucking did an entire three,
not it,
maybe not an entire three 60.
I think he just missed the gay and he just drove by it and then he couldn't go
right into it because he would have hit the other plane.
So he had to,
because it was on the right hand side.
He had a bang,
the left and we live it did like a fucking doubt.
And everybody's in the plane like,
what the fuck are we doing?
Guide a bad day.
He or she,
whoever the fuck was up front,
um,
it was hilarious.
Everybody was getting off the plane like to,
what the fuck was that?
The hell just happened.
You know what happens?
You know,
you drive down the street,
sometimes you miss the home depot is I can't fuck,
I got to go back around again.
I don't feel like doing it legally and he just fucking bang a Uie.
Right.
Well the same thing happens in aviation,
evidently have a fucking Dan Lee.
The same thing happens.
Um,
Jesus,
what the fuck is going on in Kansas City by the way?
They lost to the New York jets.
Jets.
It decent.
Good Lord.
This is why,
you know,
coaching in the NFL,
he's got to be a bitch.
Can you imagine Andy Reed after September starts to year,
they,
they fucking beat the dog.
That the fray.
We beat the dog crap.
All of them fucking patriot.
You right?
Not really.
They just dominated the fourth quarter and ran away with it at that point.
Right?
Everybody's all excited.
Holy Shit.
Then all of a sudden Tom Brady's fucking old and uh,
they'll fucking water goes down the drain that different way.
Black is white,
white.
He's black.
You don't know what the fuck's going on all the way through September.
I bet he started a building,
an addition onto his fucking house,
you know,
getting ready to put that fucking trophy in there.
And uh,
after these last two fucking months,
the last eight God damn weeks,
I would say that the,
that they've stopped the construction,
he probably has a tarp over the top of it.
Um,
I like Andy Reid.
I hope they turn it around.
I haven't been able to watch the game,
but Jesus fucking Christ,
they can't get a God damn when they cannot get a fucking win.
So,
um,
I actually watched a bunch of football today too when I,
when I landed,
I watched the Patriots first,
the bills.
I thought that was gonna be a lot closer game.
I thought tie Rod Taylor,
who is going to give us headaches.
All right,
tie Rod Taylor.
I liked that guy,
but I'll tell you right now,
he is no Russell Wilson and after watching the fucking Seattle Seahawks tonight,
uh,
I'm going to go on a limb.
I think I could block for Russell Wilson.
I could just have a guy in about eight seconds run around me and then just watch
him fucking be like this modern day Fran target that that guy is fucking
unbelievable.
I don't even know how good Seattle's offensive line is.
I don't even know if they're decent.
All I know is at the end of every game they should be giving.
They should be fucking making it rain that Russell Wilson's locker,
because they're all going to get a big contract because I guarantee you he
probably got sacked probably,
I dunno what,
three times,
four times less than he should have.
The fucking eagles were in the backfield.
Oh.
It was like every time he went back for the past,
the guy to run like an extra 40 yards until somebody got opened
the gun.
I'm like,
I dunno.
Like I felt like they got maybe two or three times that game maybe.
Um,
but Jesus Christ as that guy,
fun to watch and Seattle look to say,
I look fun.
They look really strong,
man.
That was actually kind of like root for the Eagles because,
uh,
you know,
I don't know what the Patriots are going to do.
I,
you never know when you're playing the AFC east,
you know,
that's our fucking schedules.
Like the Alabama Crimson tide,
you don't often stink.
Bill stinked at jet stink this year.
They're all fucking average.
You know what I mean?
There's literally six wins right there.
Um,
so I,
I really don't know how good we are,
but,
uh,
that was a huge game tonight.
This is what it feels like a sports podcast.
I did start off talking about fucking old people in lazy boys right there.
Nice.
And I also believe I solved the Middle Eastern crisis.
MMM.
I just watch,
I'm sorry.
I just watched a ton of fucking football and uh,
well at this point you gotta be into football if you're still listening.
So I'm not gonna apologize.
I should apologize like fucking 10 minutes ago.
But,
um,
I don't know.
The defense looked fucking great.
Richard Sherman isn't even in there.
Can I ask you guys a fucking question about the Achilles Tendon?
Why?
Why do you rupture your Achilles tendon but you tear your ACL?
Why is that?
Why don't you rupture your ACL and tear your fucking Achilles tended?
He said because your Achilles tendon goes up.
You fought back he leg like a fucking window shade.
Is that what it is?
You know what?
I'm actually going to look that up.
I'm going to look that up.
I'm gonna put this fucking urban myth.
This is it a metal.
Now it's not.
It's uh,
uh,
I dunno.
It's a fucking question I have.
Why do you rupture a,
that's not going to come out right?
Your Achilles.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait it out because there'll be like,
cause you fucking didn't stretch.
That's the wrong way to search.
How about
rupture?
Verse Tear.
Achilles.
All right,
let's see what we got here.
What do we got here?
Achilles tendon rupture is an injury that affects the back of your lower leg.
Oh,
is that where it is?
Jesus Christ.
All right.
It mainly occurs in people playing recreational sports.
That means white guys playing pickup hoop.
Every fucking white dude I know over the age of 40,
35,
40,
who still plays hoops,
every one of them gets to Colby injury,
but it can happen to anyone.
That's why before you get out of bed,
if you're a fucking old person,
especially an old white guy.
All right?
I don't know.
I mean the many black guys other than than,
than fucking Richard Sherman and Coby Bryan like superstar black guys do it
right,
but average white people just all the fucking time.
I'm just making up shit here before you get out of bed in the morning.
I'm telling you,
if you,
if you run a little tight,
okay,
I'm telling you,
I've said this before,
you fucking take your toes pointing at your knees slowly.
All right?
And if you get an a,
if you get a fucking Charlie horse in your fucking calves immediately point your
toes in the other direction and a little release.
Okay?
But if you don't,
just point in your fucking do it right now.
Your desk,
what the fuck are you not doing?
Shit right?
But when you sit down,
right,
don't do it.
Wait til you fucking laid out.
Don't listen to me,
but I'm still going to Talki right.
Point your toes at your niece and your kneecaps.
I saw you do.
And you just do that for a good,
I don't know,
1520 seconds,
right?
Then you pointed with the other direction that the fucking wall or whatever in
front of you,
all right,
your dog that's laying on the end of your bed,
okay?
Then once you do that for 15 seconds,
then you roll your fucking feet clockwise a couple times and counter clockwise.
Then you get out of bed.
Don't just lay there for fucking eight hours sleeping with you,
God damn apnea and then just pop out of bed and take that first step because
you're going to get you get you get you going to be fucked.
Planter Fisher,
it's all that bullshit.
All right,
let's,
let's continue with the Achilles tendon.
Is he strong?
Fiber is cord that connects the muscles in the back of your calf to your heel
bone.
If you overstretch your Achilles tendon,
it can tear.
Fuck,
wait a minute.
I thought it was cause you didn't tear slash rupture completely or just
partially.
If you're killies tendon ruptures,
you might hear a pop followed by an immediate bitch like scream that appears to
come from your mouth area.
No followed by an immediate sharp pain in the back of your ankle and lower leg.
That is likely to affect your ability to walk properly.
Surgery is often performed to repair the rupture for many people over
nonsurgical treatment works just as well.
This is not answering my fucking question.
Why do they say rupture?
Okay.
For Kelly's,
I can't believe I know how to spell Achilles.
It's how big a fucking Zeplin Fan I am.
I spelled it wrong.
Achilles tendon ruptures,
Jersey.
What
to do if you tell it.
You know what?
I don't even give a fuck anymore.
Somebody has got to be a Goddamn doctor or a first responder.
Who could fucking tell me what it means.
Um,
all right,
let me read a little,
uh,
advertising here for the week.
Ah,
ZIP recruiter,
everybody.
Ladies and gentlemen,
it's all zip.
Okay.
But
with Ziprecruiter,
you can post your job to over 100 Web's leading job boards with just one click
so you can rest easy knowing your job is being seen by the right candidates.
That all zip
puts its smart matching technology to work actively notifying qualified
candidates about your job within minutes of posting so you can receive the best
possible mass matches.
No wonder 80% of employees who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate.
The site in just one day.
Even pimps advertise on this and the easy to use zip
bre
parlor dashboard lets you manage your hiring process from start to finish all in
one place.
Zip the smartest way to hire.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has been used by growing businesses of all sizes
and industries to find out the most qualified job candidates with immediate
results.
And right now my listeners can post on old zip
for free.
That's right free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/decode that's ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] one more
time for free.
You go to zip.
Okay.
group.com/pat.
All right.
Oh look who's here if your buddy,
ah,
but it would doto brds beyond these what's going on in Kansas City to do to me
Mondays,
Mondays and he reads,
got sweaty titties.
He showed to put that shit on the side of his house.
He's going to get fired.
Then they'll hire a fucking Laos because that's what Kansas City does.
They torture their fans.
What the fuck happened?
He's Superbowl dreams.
Um,
Miyagi's.
Anyway,
everybody let me tell you about me undies.
It's the only underwear that makes for an amazing gift.
Soft,
flexible waistband three times softer than cotton.
Naturally sustainable source to fiber.
Mandy's maid underwear.
The perfect gift that everyone is going to love for you.
It's a God damn holiday miracle.
You fucking bastard this year.
Don't give underwear.
Give me undies.
Uh,
this holiday season.
But do we do B?
It's the holiday season.
You want soft shit up against your nuts.
Not Literally Frequent Madel matter.
Ah,
I can't fucking sing this holiday season.
Doobie Doobie.
Do to get your exclusive 20% off the softest underwear and socks you'll ever
wear.
Free Shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to be undies.
Com slash.
Bar.
That's me undies,
dotcom.
Slash.
Bar.
How many fucking more do we got here?
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody if you want to shave your balls are just look like you have shaped
balls.
Jess,
uh,
use dollar shave club just like their razors.
Everything is super high quality and what have you.
Looking and feeling amazing.
Shave your nuts,
get some fucking me undies and then fucking find somebody.
Lick your balls on Ziprecruiter.
You like how I'm tying it all together.
And then when you go to court,
mail something through stamps.com from premium ingredients to sophisticated
sense dollar shave club is changing the game.
If you're sick of the nonsense at the store,
now's the time to try out dollar shave club for a limited time.
Dollar Shave Club is basically giving away their shit.
Shower,
shave starter set to new members for only $5 to start a set features their
executive razor and three trial size versions of their most popular products
that help you stay fresh and clean.
And your first box you will receive their shave butter bodywash and one wipe
Charlies.
But wipes.
Speaking of Charlie,
I watched Ken Burns' the end of that is fucking thing on the Vietnam War.
It's incredible.
But anyways,
you will also receive their executive,
he sir,
which includes their premium,
weighty handle and focus set of cartridges and the first box replacement
cartridges are sent for only a few bucks a month.
This offer is exclusively available@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr that's dollar
shave club.com/bar and if you want a great gift,
give him dollar Shave Club.
I just said this shit that got,
they've got super simple gift memberships and he giftcards dollar shave club's
high quality products.
We'll have you covered from face cheeks to butt cheeks.
There's no better time to try the club.
You know it's cool.
Isn't that Ken Burns the war.
They had a north Vietnamese soldier,
I swear to God.
His first name was boo and he wrote a book about his experiences and I got to
read that fucking thing.
It's always great to hear what the other side was thinking.
You know what I mean?
It humanizes them,
but they're fucking scared.
They miss their family.
You know what I mean?
It's well that never works in sports.
You go to somebody else's state and still like,
I don't like these fucking cuts.
All right.
stamps.com everybody.
Wow.
They cut off all the copy that just starts with,
so do what I do.
Use stamps.com instead,
uh,
I've done this copy enough.
I can memorize.
Hey everybody,
this holiday season do we do be do,
don't go to the post office.
Stand behind all those old people that took a shower with sitting in a fucking
lazy boy.
You know you're going to be there.
They're going to have all kinds of fucking questions.
You're not going to know what to do,
right?
Fuck.
All of that shit wouldn't be great if he just do it from your own house.
Whether that be wonderful would be great if you just do everything from your
house.
That's a different story.
All right,
do what I do.
Go to use stamps.com stamps.com brings all the services of the US post office
right into your goddamn house.
Buy and print official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class a mail,
using your own computer and printer,
you bringing the post office into your house,
rednecks with guns.
Relax.
It's not literally a stranger in your house.
Okay?
It's just figured.
Leave speaking figuratively speaking.
Put Your Goddamn gun down.
Then the mailman picks it up.
Don't shoot him.
Stamps.
Dot coms makes it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale,
automatically calculates exact postage stamps.com we'll even help you decide out
of the fucking the best class of mail every time.
Print postage any day,
anytime stamps.com is always open.
I use stamps.com anytime I sent out my fucking posters and I want to get
sexually assaulted by drunk cougars at the end of the fucking show.
And right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and digital scale.
Without long term commitments,
go to stamps.com
click on the microphone
page and type in Berg,
but you are that stamps.com enter borough right mercifully that is fucking over.
Um,
all right,
38 fucking minutes in here.
Then I talk about everything.
I wanted to talk about it.
I did it that night.
Then I do know,
um,
oh,
you know what?
I ordered this old modern drummer because it was right around the time John
Bonham died and they had this little John Bonham retrospective.
I thought they're going to be a little more shocked that he was gone.
They just kind of said,
you know,
he's one of the great drummers of all time.
He has all his beats and all that shit.
You know,
it's real.
It's really cool.
One,
like what's his face is on the cover.
Let me see what's on the,
I don't even know who's on the cover.
It's from so long ago.
It's 1981.
Um,
hang on a second.
Hang on a second.
As I walk across the room,
it's uh,
oh shit.
It's Peter Criss,
Peter,
Chris,
and he's sitting,
I swear to God,
he is playing a pearl drum kit with concert Tom's,
but you novices out there,
that means there's no bottom heads.
If you ever watch Phil Collins,
that's what he yet right and uh,
are still has,
he has a kick and a snare and then he has one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven rack toms and two floor toms.
So he has an 11 piece kit to play at one Oh rock and roll.
All Nat,
the Impartner ever read date,
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo
Doo Doo Doo Doo.
[inaudible] four hours later I butted did,
I did about data but it has crashed.
Uh,
that's what I like about these old fuck these fet fucking kid is the shit.
And then they got like back then they had all of these,
uh,
they got these fucking drum kits.
Do you guys remember when David had the,
on the bass drum they'd have the,
the mount two toms and then they'd have a third one there.
When I opened this up,
Ludwig,
they've always had the inside front cover.
They actually,
this guy from reo Speedwagon Allen Grad,
sir,
he has four fucking times and a fuck.
Even reach those ones up top.
Unbelievable.
Anyways,
I love looking at this shit.
You look at like the bass drum pedals that they had and this was like the 80s
this was like 15 years after John Bonham did good times.
Bad Times.
So I can't,
I mean,
you know,
I know.
He was like the Ludwig speaking.
Look at Peter.
Chris has kid fucking British racing green.
He looks good man.
He looks good without the makeup back in 1981 anyways,
I don't know.
I'm into that old shit.
I'm sorry.
I don't know what the fuck I brought that up.
I just want to bore you guys to tear.
All right.
Tear sparky.
41 minutes and I can start reading it.
God knows the way I fucking read.
Does anybody know how you fucking,
do you remember your iCloud password or your Instagram password?
I just fucking,
I just,
once I lose them and then I just,
I can't,
it's like I can't get into my own house.
Right.
Girlfriend's friend's boyfriend.
Demands and apology.
Okay.
Girlfriend's friend's boyfriend.
Yeah.
All right,
so you have a girlfriend who has a friend who was a boyfriend and they want an
apology from you.
Dear Burbank,
bad boy brain redbird,
redbird,
whatever the fuck that means.
A Bill Burbank.
That's going to be my fucking alias.
A,
I've got an interesting one for you.
A little bit of context.
I am 24 and two years out of school.
I live with my girlfriend of almost five years,
roughly two years ago on a sorority trip with my girlfriend,
her friend and her friend's boyfriend.
I gave the girl one of those awkward side hugs after she went out for a beer
run.
No sexual intent whatsoever just to thank you.
Evidently the boyfriend felt otherwise and flew into a rage shortly thereafter
and salting the girl and my girlfriend.
I didn't learn about this until well after and since I have no relationship with
the guy.
Okay.
Was content to let it be now wait a minute.
Did the guys see the side hug?
All right,
wait,
or what the fuck happened?
I gave the girl of one of one of those awkward side hugs have to,
she went out for a beer run.
No sexual intent,
whatever,
just to thank you.
Evidently the boyfriend felt otherwise.
If flew into a rage shortly after,
I guess he waited till you leave on this guy a pussy.
That,
what are you worried about?
If he was fucking there,
but she called him up.
Ah,
me fucking
touched this opposite side.
Shoulder of mine.
All right.
Flash Florida for two years later,
the two of them have just gotten engaged.
My girlfriend will be a bridesmaid and learned from the other girl.
I will not be invited to the wedding unless I apologize to the boyfriend now go
fuck yourself.
Fuck this fucking pussy.
Why does he call you up?
Yeah,
he did good.
You May.
Where do you this?
You apologize me.
Why is this woman marrying this guy two years later,
he's still mad about a side hug.
Jesus Christ.
How possessive as this fucking maniac.
I feel bad for the woman that's married this lunatic.
Alright for inappropriately touching his girl.
Well,
dude,
by the way,
I'm just hearing your side of the story,
you know,
did you do one of those awkward side hugs?
And then Jan came off her shoulder and accidentally went across their ass.
If it was just an awkward side Hug,
I say,
fuck this guy.
Out of respect for my girlfriend,
I'm tempted to apologize.
But since an apology is an admission of guilt and I didn't do anything wrong,
my pride is holding me back.
You know what?
Because you just said that actually believe in you.
I actually believe you.
I'm surprised that he's been too cowardly to approach me and it's having to work
through to people to get what he wants.
What we do do.
Uh,
you know what I would do?
I would,
I would go fucking find out what sports is playing in that area.
Tell my girlfriend to have a good time at the fucking wedding.
Love the podcast.
Love to stand up.
Thanks.
Um,
this is what I would say.
I would just say I did nothing wrong,
so I'm not apologizing and tell that groom to be congratulations on getting
married.
And at some point he might want to grow a Dick if he wants to be the man of the
house.
I'll get some fucking balls,
dude.
Fuck that guy.
Five would go to a fucking tractor pull before I would go to the fucking
wedding.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
You'll be fucking hilarious.
Go to the wedding anyways.
And then after they fucking exchange their goddamn vows,
go up and give her a side hug.
Yeah,
Dude.
Fuck that.
I don't feel,
I don't see your letter that does any pressure from your now girlfriend.
Um,
you know,
however,
if you don't go,
she,
you know,
she might be,
or what the fat gaming guy an hour less than,
as in they're getting married.
You mean you really flex my ring?
You might have to go down that road,
but I got to tell you.
Yeah,
this might be a twofer.
You very human dating this woman for five fucking years.
You're not giving her a ring.
So what the fuck did I say?
You dump your current girlfriend and tell that guy to go fuck himself.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
I'd dump everybody in this fucking story.
Sorry I'm a little grumpy.
Don't listen to me,
but I definitely wouldn't apologize to that guy.
And I would go to the wedding.
I mean,
you're a guy who the fuck wants to go to a wedding.
This is great.
You got an hour.
All right?
And just stay with that.
I just can't do it because they feel it's an admission of guilt.
And during this sensitive time is climate and worried that did this.
If they,
if they see,
I'm sorry there,
Dennis was somehow going to meet Instagram,
which is tailored to me,
Facebook and overdue my Twitter and I may not get a job.
Just call that fucking room.
Or You could just be a man and just see and then apologize and that gay.
Fuck him.
All right.
And then you,
you're fucking girlfriend.
Year duty.
We,
me,
I would love to go,
but I'm not going under those circumstances.
And I'll tell you right now,
if you didn't do shit in the fucking bride wanted,
you apologize and you didn't want to,
I would back you.
So I'm not going.
If you want to go,
you can go off.
You know,
I'd go and get over here and blow me and let's go to the game day.
You Go.
That's what you're saying.
All right.
Boyfriend rides.
Motocross.
Dear Bill,
I love all your work and your comedy.
Thank you.
You're so inspire of Jesus Christ.
[inaudible] okay.
Where'd I'd like where?
I'd like your input.
Here we go.
I'm seriously dating someone who loves to ride and race motocross.
That's fucking awesome.
I bet.
I bet this isn't the same woman from the last one.
You know?
I bet this is the guy that's getting married.
The motocross guy.
This guy is fucking cool.
This guy doesn't like a fucking side hug.
He's just going to fucking punch you in the face with his motorcycle gloves to,
right.
Uh,
we've been together for over a year,
so I'm starting to think about marriage and a family with this person because
they're both 25.
Well,
that's,
that makes sense.
Uh,
he's awesome in every way.
And the person I know I want to be with forever.
Well,
they go,
but he loves to ride and race motocross.
It's not on the professional level.
It's a hobby.
Aww Sweetheart.
You're going to do this.
You're going to take away his fucking hobby.
We had a talk recently where I asked him how long he wants to keep riding.
And he said forever.
I know someone who has two children who husband had an accident riding a dirt
bike.
He's paralyzed and doesn't remember who his kids are.
Uh,
well,
Jesus Christ is,
people will get in cars.
I mean,
come on,
man.
What are you,
what are you doing?
This,
this is,
come on.
I'll tell you right now,
if you,
if this guy who you want to marry,
if you want to make them fucking miserable,
we'll have to explain this to my boyfriend.
He said his,
something's going to happen to me.
It will,
whether I'm riding motocross or not,
I'm not going to change what I love doing because of fear of what could happen.
Uh,
I gotta tell you this.
I have,
I understand why you love this guy.
I'm starting to develop feelings for this guy.
He's holding his ground.
He's riding motorcycles,
and we date the fucking Marlboro man here.
Um,
I,
I think that's a selfish response when it involves your children.
Hate to try and,
well,
you're getting,
you don't have any kids yet.
All right.
You said,
I hate to try to convince him to stop something he loves doing so much,
but I can't imagine being with someone who participates in an extreme sport as a
hobby when I have children with them.
Is it wrong of me to ask them to promise to stop and we have kids or am I being
controlling?
Uh,
well first of all,
the fact that you asked that you're a cool person.
All right?
If you're actually questioning your behavior,
this is the thing.
I think you're a little further ahead emotionally in this relationship than when
he's at where most women are.
All right?
Uh,
and this is the thing,
when you become a dad,
you do change.
All right?
So that rather than fucking Nag him about this shit,
just let the guy ride and if you get married,
okay,
I'm telling you right now,
when you get married and you have a fucking kid,
this guy is going to be so fucking sleep deprived.
And so God damn tired,
he's not going to have time to ride.
Okay.
Though as much as it used to,
which will then make it safer cause he's not writing as much.
But,
um,
I think there's a big thing you can't,
when you love somebody,
you have to let them do what they love unless it's heroin.
Okay.
Or being a pedophile.
Obvious fucking thinks.
All right.
But other,
do you know
if my wife liked all of a sudden wanted to be one of those roller Derby Queens,
as much as it wouldn't fucking destroy me.
Watching her taking those bumps as the elbow and them was there skating around
if she really loved doing it.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
I wouldn't tell her not to fucking do it.
I really would be worried about concussions.
It's shit like that.
I would be,
I'm not going to lie to you,
but,
um,
you got to let people do what they do.
Uh,
it sounds like you've got a really cool guy that you're dating by the way,
so congratulations.
Um,
and I think you're going to be a great mom cause you're doing what a mom does.
A mom's already looking way into the future,
trying to figure out where the danger is and try to eliminate it.
All right.
So thank you both.
Lucky to have each other just fucking relax.
Get yourself a god damn glass of wine.
Let the guy ride his bike.
You know,
you guys get married some day,
I'm telling you,
what do you get fucking knocked up and all of a sudden he's got to go to seven
11.
You know,
cause you want beef jerky in a fucking fucking,
I don't know,
when did some God damn ice cream whenever you're craving is,
uh,
you know,
believe me,
like I have had to make adjustments in my life.
Um,
I think you'll be fine,
but uh,
you definitely really,
you know,
they would say a good man's hard to find a good woman is also hard to find.
And the fact that you're cool enough to actually be considering,
am I being a Douche share?
Uh,
I think you guys are going to be all right.
All right,
there you go.
Alright.
Neighbor,
neighbor invasion.
Okay,
dear Billy mango tits.
I don't know what that means.
It's bizarre and I like it.
All right.
I am an older lady,
uh,
who just moved into a sweet cottage in the boondocks last month.
All right.
I met my next door neighbor before I moved in and I liked her instantly and she
seemed warm and funny as it turned out.
She's a Kramer in the first week she came knocking on my door numerous times for
social calls.
Oh No.
And she will stay for long periods of time.
Even if I tell her I'm busy and she won't sit down.
So I feel like a captive audience to her monologues.
I'm a solitary person and I don't like peeping people coming over unannounced
unless it's an emergency.
This ain't,
this ain't right.
Little House,
a little house on the prairie.
I have told her firmly on numerous occasions to fucking stop it.
Oh,
good for you.
You're a strong person.
And I like it.
And that would appreciate her emailing me and waiting for a response or leaving
a note if she wants to hang.
I'm not sure how much more clear I can be,
uh,
that I'm uncomfortable with the situation.
Especially when I see her face in my kitchen window at night,
waving me down.
It scares the shit out of me.
Yeah.
That made me uncomfortable.
She's even knocked on my bathroom window when I didn't answer the door.
I don't wish to be mean.
Oh No,
you gotta be me.
You have to be mean.
Uh,
since I live next to her,
I know she's lonely and well,
yeah,
cause she's a fucking lunatic.
Were kind of Guinea went,
look what she's doing to you and you don't even live with their,
can you imagine living with this woman to be like that thing an alien that's on
those fucking people's faces.
Um,
I know she is lonely and it,
and I liked to be friends with her,
but she,
but she just no comprendo love your podcast and advice and thanks you ginger
Moose knuckle for not being a sex offender because all my heroes are going down.
Uh,
well,
you know,
it's still early in this game.
You know,
someone could accuse me of something.
God knows.
It doesn't matter what the fuck.
I mean,
I don't know.
Nobody really innocent.
Nobody who seemed innocent has fucking,
uh,
seem to have been called out yet.
You know,
I,
a couple of people have been like,
I've never met that woman in my life and then it fucking goes away.
So I think it's all right.
Right.
It still makes you nervous as a guy going,
Jesus Christ,
you know,
this whole trial by social media is kind of scary over there.
All right,
let's stay with the,
uh,
the,
the topic here.
Um,
I don't,
I don't know what I would just be,
look all,
I can't tell you what to do.
All I can tell you is what I would do.
All right.
I would do what you already did.
And um,
all right.
You want to know what I would do when she knocks on the door?
I'd be like,
get Outta here.
Fuck off.
I would do that.
And when she knocked on my window and scared the shit out of me,
I'd be like,
dude,
are you Outta your fucking mind?
You're scaring the shit out of me.
I want to be friends with you,
but you suffocate me.
You asshole.
All right.
Do you want to be friends with me?
Yes or no?
Yes.
Great.
Then stop being a fucking jerk off.
Stop knocking on my fucking door and my window.
Stop crying.
Alright.
Come on in.
I'm in.
I'm sorry.
Let me make it some lemonade.
She's one of those people.
Um,
I dunno.
I Dunno why.
I Dunno what I would I get a BB gun?
Maybe shoot her in the fucking knee as she comes over.
Maybe she'll think it's a beehive or some shit.
I don't know what I would do.
I Dunno what the fuck I would do a,
if you've actually told her that she sounds like a crazy person,
why would you want to be friends with a crazy person?
I think he just got it.
You can just got to ignore.
Okay.
Like the next time she knocks on her.
When you window like that,
I would just knock back on the same on the other side of the window.
I'd knocked back and then give her the finger,
see how she handles that.
That's one way to do it.
The other way to do it is to start talking about shit that freaks her out of,
she's really religious.
Just talk about how much you love Satan and you've given yourself over to him.
Uh,
I dunno what else you could do fart in her presence.
I Dunno.
I'd have no idea.
I don't know what to do.
I feel bad for you.
Um,
for some reason it reminded me of misery.
I just keep picturing that woman walking up to the window,
the CACA duty,
whatever.
Fucking come up to the window.
It's very American horror story.
A wife cries at least.
So I hope that helps you out.
Um,
I would just be more firm.
Write her a letter,
dear neighbor.
Fuck off.
Sincerely,
uh,
solitary woman in college,
cottage next to you,
right?
All right.
Wife cries at least three times a week.
Dear bill burr bag.
It's a big fan of you.
Of your f you attitude towards life.
I don't have a fuck you attitude towards life.
Okay.
I think it's very precious and know that I am taking notes by telling people to
go fuck yourself.
All right.
Anyways.
Anyways,
I have an issue with my wife to be because she cries all the time.
All right.
That's a deal breaker for me.
Uh,
Ari,
I already have my advice.
Next time she cries,
just gently put your hands on her shoulders and be like,
honey,
grow up.
No,
you can't do it.
Right.
We've known each other since January,
2017 and our marriage was arranged,
not forced,
but arranged.
All right.
This is like tear and rupture.
What the fuck does that mean?
We both chose to marry each other after our parents allowed us to talk on the
phone for a few months.
Oh,
what the fuck is this?
What?
In what in guide?
Well,
of course she did.
If they left,
if they didn't allow you to talk on the fucking phone the first time,
you poke your head out of the ground.
Yeah,
you're gonna,
you're gonna marry whatever you do just to get away from those controlling
maniacs.
Anyways,
since we've been together and she's cried more times than I've cried in my life,
including the Times I've cried during my childhood.
Everything.
She's crying because she doesn't want to marry you.
That's what I'd be worried about.
She cries for various different reasons like her little sister annoys her.
Yeah.
Feels like she's lucky to have me.
Feels like her parents don't value her or she feels like she won't do me proud
as a wife.
Oh my God.
I don't even know what to do with this person.
But you know that you seem like you're from a different part of the world and
different cultures so,
but you,
you do seem annoyed but oh my God,
Jesus fucking Christ.
I,
I think I would start crying.
I just be,
if you,
if you don't stop fucking crying,
I swear to God I'm going to kill myself and that would make her cry even more
and just be like,
what do I have to do?
Okay.
Anyways,
we are definitely getting married is that line has been crossed.
So cutting it off.
Is it a possibility to where the fuck are you in the world?
I love her more than you love the freckles on your face,
but,
but this is crying is wearing me down.
Okay,
well it seems like you still have a sense of humor about it as I have to comfort
her every time and just stare at her on facetime and she cries at times.
It just gets super annoying because she does cry over small shit.
I got to tell you something.
I don't know this woman and she's already,
she's annoying the shit out of me.
Anyway,
she has a busy schedule because she's training to be a teacher.
Oh God.
I hope she doesn't fucking teach them under privileged kids.
She'll have a god damn nervous breakdown.
Second she starts crying and shows weakness.
It's going to be over anyways,
getting a Postgrad,
organizing Islamic events,
parentheses,
no isis jokes please.
And she does an Islamic course at night,
so I understand that she has shitloads on her plate.
She's under confident and she feels like she's not the model woman you see on
Instagram.
Although I assure her that she is beautiful and I love her just the way she is.
I really don't know how to deal with this or even approach the situation.
Sometimes I find that I am avoiding her because I know a lady will lead to
crying.
And what you have you,
what do you suggest
your podcast is?
Sex to my ears.
Nia is awesome and I hope Lola is not giving me a too many sleepless nights.
Thank you for listening.
Old Bright Bulb.
Beg Billy.
Uh,
Jesus fucking Christ.
MMM.
I don't know what to tell you dude.
Okay.
I really,
I really don't know what the fuck to tell you.
Aye.
I don't know how to solve this.
This is like,
how do you tell a woman to stop crying in a way that doesn't make them cry more.
All right.
Okay.
You know what I do when my wife is going to cry and I don't think it's that big
a deal at or I just don't want to deal with it.
Okay.
When she to cry.
I just look at her and I jut out my bottom lip and I make the saddest,
most pathetic.
Let's just picture like a sad clown.
I make the saddest,
stupid face,
stupid his face and I looked down while still looking up at her.
Just imagine that look and it always makes her laugh and she gets fucking mad at
me because she can't continue crying because they look so fucking ridiculous and
okay.
Another way you could do it is bright.
Before you make that face,
she'd take a big inhale.
You Go,
Oh man,
you just make that face and I'm telling you if you,
if she has a sense of fucking humor,
that's what I would do.
I think that's what I would do.
I would just joke my way out of it.
Anytime she was crying over nothing,
I would start crying with her
like,
I just don't feel that I'm going to be good enough has been for you.
It'd be like,
oh,
and then I would just be like,
now you have to know this.
I am a dick.
All right.
But that's what I would do.
I would just start doing that and what's going to happen is hopefully she'll
toughen up a little bit.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
Do you know how fucking nervous that would make me if a woman was crying because
she loves me that much and was worried that she wouldn't be a good fucking,
I would break up with her.
I'd be like,
I can't handle that pressure.
Jesus.
Chris,
what is going to happen when she finds out?
I can't fucking read out loud.
A mom's comment on pizza.
Good luck to you,
sir.
That's what I would do.
I would use humor.
How would use humor?
Okay.
You know,
next time she goes,
honey,
can I talk to you about something?
I would have like 40 fucking boxes of Kleenex and just fucking run over with
like five boxes of Kleenexes.
I would just do something to make it silly and ridiculous
and then she might get upset that you do that.
I guess I would then say,
uh,
the fuck would I say.
I would just be honest.
Just say,
listen,
I,
I love you to death.
But
yeah,
you delete the amount that you cry.
I don't know how to deal with it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh fuck that made you cry.
Jesus Christ.
What do you guys say?
What do you,
what do you Islamic guys say when you curse?
Okay.
What do you,
what do you say instead of Jesus Christ?
what do,
what do you say?
Do you say something?
You Take d,
take Muhammad's name in vain.
Do you do something like that and with the whatever the fuck it is you say,
I would,
I would be really a,
that would really,
I mean,
that's a lot.
These fucking letters are a lot this week.
Okay.
The fucking neighbor,
the God damn fucking Douche bag.
Who needs an apology for a fucking side hug through two different women?
He needs to get his apology.
Yeah.
That guy is such a pussy.
What kind of fucking guy on invites another guy to a fucking wedding as if
that's some sort of punishment.
He just made his day.
You asshole.
If you really didn't like the side hug,
you should make him fucking go there.
Um,
and then there's the one cool check of fucking boyfriend rights.
Motorcross all right.
Let's say the other people were cool,
but could lord wife cries at least three times a week.
I read that it's three times a day.
Three times a week.
That's still a lot.
156 times a year.
That's what I would do.
All right.
Three 65 minus one 56.
Oh Jesus.
Two 56 to 50.
That's 194 194 days.
You're not crying.
156 you are.
Okay.
That's like Marty Schottenheimer's lifetime record that like that's the way
you're crying.
Days you cry versus days you don't,
and that's not enough to make it in this league.
Okay?
So I'm going to need you to toughen it up at least two thirds more.
Why don't you tell us she,
she's allowed to cry once a week unless something really bad happens.
Okay.
Um,
you know,
you could do,
you could go to the pet store and get one of those shocker college and every
time she starts to cry just fucking sapper.
Um,
I dunno.
I Dunno what to tell you.
All right.
Mom's comment on pizza leads to break up.
I have no idea where this is going.
All right.
Hey bill weekly listener here.
Love F is for family and all your standup stuff.
Keep up the good work.
My question is what experiences,
okay.
Ah,
good to see you.
Come on in.
Come on in
a knee at this guy's fucking wife.
Christ.
Three times a week.
Why?
That's hilarious.
Did you guys here?
Then she goes,
why are you going to cry?
She cries because she loves him so much.
She just did a spit take.
I swear to God.
She does.
Yes she does.
Nobody loves somebody that much.
They cry at the,
that was the,
well this is the thing that they're there.
They're Islamic and their parents allowed them like,
well listen,
knock it off.
Exactly.
I was telling him what I do when you cry baby at that time when you would cry
and I just kept making that face.
I go,
which was not helpful by the way.
It helped me cause I just didn't want to deal.
You tell me if I'm crying,
I'm having an emotion about something and I tell you something.
My job isn't to like checkout and figuring out how to wait for you to deal with
it.
Your job is to like check in and figure out how I can deal with it.
Your job was to make me feel better,
not cope for yourself.
God,
you have a,
sometimes you just don't want to deal with like you know when I know when I
occasionally want to deal just fucking deal being nice person,
be emotionally open,
don't be a fucking vast wasteland of non emotion.
Man.
Are you?
Hi.
Yes you are.
Nobody cries.
She's lying cause she's not crying that much cause she loves him.
Can I tell you something like you know,
occasionally I'll get upset and I go on a rant.
Wouldn't it be great if he knew how to,
what your version of that is when you cry?
No,
it is.
No it is no,
don't tell me how I feel.
Don't tell me how I react to things.
I don't cry.
Like,
don't respond to my,
don't tell me what your,
don't tell me.
Angry.
I'm angry.
If I'm emotional,
I'm fucking emotional.
Hey,
can I finish this?
These people are Islamic.
This is an arranged marriage.
It's,
it's not forced to listen for fuck sakes.
Can we get old binding them?
Like,
all right.
They actually were allowed to talk on the fucking phone for a few months.
Okay.
So yeah,
these are,
these are fucking,
you know,
this is very respective,
secluded life here.
I got it.
So,
you know,
she's,
her emotions are at the surface,
so she cries if for little sister annoys her,
if she feels she feels she's lucky to have me.
Feels like her parents don't value her or she feels like she won't do me proud
as a wife.
Oh.
So whenever she's having emotions basically,
right.
What's a good way to be like,
honey,
I love you to death,
but could you fucking knock it off because you're driving me crazy?
How do you say that to a woman without making her cry more?
Uh,
I mean,
yeah,
she seems like she would cry if you told him.
If you told her like,
you know,
I don't know.
The t was not sweet enough,
so she's definitely a sensitive,
I told him to start crying too.
Like she's just like,
I'm just worried.
I was like,
and I was thinking that she would get mad the probably because if she did it
like that,
cause that's it.
Then she stops crying.
Hey,
hang in here for this last one.
Is that me?
No,
I don't know.
Honestly,
I have no idea what I can tell you as a man,
when a woman cries,
all we want you to do is to stop crying.
We don't give a fuck.
Yes.
Completely fucking selfish when it comes to our emotions.
Yeah.
We know you're selfish when I yelled,
that's an emotion.
You want me to stop yelling,
yelling,
like hearing somebody yell constantly.
It's like traumatic.
Okay.
When somebody cry all the time is also traumatic.
It's like you're watching a sad movie that never ends.
It is.
No,
that would be a real,
she sounds like a real drip,
you know Jesus.
All right.
Well what can he do?
I don't know.
Oh boy.
Oh boy,
buddy.
It sounds like that's just kinda how she is.
I mean,
I don't know if your religion allows you to do this,
but I would get some Bose wireless headphones,
the noise canceling ones.
Whenever she starts crying,
I just put them on and put on your favorite fucking music.
Can you ask her dad or her mom or whatever?
Like just,
I just feel like she's very sensitive.
She cries easily,
you know?
Is that,
yeah.
I don't know.
I wouldn't do that,
but they finally let her talk on the fucking phone and then you're going to come
and be like,
yeah,
you know?
Can you tweak it a little bit this way?
Anyway,
mom,
mom's comment on pizza leads to break up.
Hey bill weekly listener loveF is for family and all your standup stuff.
Keep up the good work.
All right.
My question is,
what experiences have you had with dating while going through our of,
hey,
a rough time with your professional career?
Bill has never dated anyone besides me.
I'm the only woman in his life that matters and I really don't appreciate you
asking about the people that came before me.
I gotta tell you something.
I dated a lot of great women,
lot of Hardee's.
There were absolute animals in the rack.
Uh,
my girlfriend and I dated for three years and recently decided to go on a break.
Yeah,
right.
You're breaking up a,
we met in law school,
both graduated with good grades and each pass the bar exam.
The big difference between us is that she got a job right after graduation with
the high salary,
insane benefits and located in a wealthy suburb.
This was largely due to a family connection,
which she openly admits.
Yeah,
good for her.
Use your connection.
Meanwhile,
I hope to get hired by a firm I worked at during my final year of law school,
but was told that the last minute that none of the interns would be hired you
fucking cunts.
Oh my God.
After he sat there going through their card catalog and one of the fuck it is
you guys do.
As a result.
I've been living with my parents for the past three months,
making money,
teaching tennis lessons while sending resumes and traveling for interviews all
over the state.
The decision for a break came when my girlfriend was visiting me at my parents'
house.
She and I went out for pizza and came back with some leftovers by girlfriend,
put the pizza in the fridge.
But my mom,
who has a heavy Russian accent,
told her that putting the pizza in the fridge destroys the flavor.
I did not even bat an eye at the interaction and went to the couch to watch a
hockey game.
These guys live in the life.
He's living at home.
He's teaching tennis,
he's watching hockey's eating pizza.
I love this guy's life.
After an evening of my girlfriend moping around,
I asked her what was wrong.
According to her,
I failed to stand up for her and it was supposed to tell my mom to not speak to
her that way.
Well,
in defense of her,
not to put the pizza in the fridge.
Yeah,
but in defense of her though,
the Russian accent is a little harsh.
They can't help it.
Even when they're being like happy and friendly towards each other,
they sound like they're screaming at each other.
They want to murder each other.
Yeah.
That they're going to send you to the fucking gulag.
Don't get mad at me.
You know that shit is true and like think about your grandparents and your aunts
and your uncles,
like when you went in the room,
nobody gets mad at anything on this podcast Neah I have,
I have curated some of the dumbest people on this planet and we all just sit in
there fucking bubble of stupidity,
enjoying all of this.
All right.
After an evening of my girlfriend moping around,
I asked her what was wrong.
Okay.
Coordinator.
What I failed to stand up for him was supposed to tell my mom to not speak to
her that way.
I know my mom could sound a little harsh with her accent.
Yeah,
there you go.
And sometimes uses incorrect words.
Use your imagination when speaking English,
but the two have always had a good relationship,
so there was no reason to think she would be upset by the comment.
This started an argument about how I've become a mama's boy.
Oh boy.
Oh,
she went there and that I'm not,
and then I'm not desperate enough to move out of the house.
Ooh,
somebody is going to throw a chair soon.
These comments really pissed me off because she has personally seen the amount
of hard work and long hours I put into my schoolwork,
internship,
passing the bar exam,
and not to mention she got a hookup and sending out resume.
Additionally,
this came a day after I was informed that I was close a close second for a job I
was excited about potentially receiving.
Yeah,
so this is it.
Yeah.
You seen branches,
you know,
land is coming.
You like Christopher Columbus.
MMM.
Nia was commenting on this all natural ginger Ale.
I actually like it,
but really quickly,
can I just ask a quick question?
Do you consider a Ginger Ale soda?
I think that as we do,
I consider ginger ale offensive and offensive name.
Do you consider Ginger Ale soda?
Yes.
You do?
Yeah.
People that follow me on Twitter on know what I'm talking about.
I did a poll on Twitter because I realized that I don't consider a Ginger Ale
soda.
Well,
it's because you only drink it when you have,
when your stomach's,
not everybody was saying to me,
but you know,
I'm obsessed with Ginger Ale so I drink it all the time.
But people seem to,
yeah.
Why don't you consider it soda?
Oh No,
I have no idea.
I consider soda like coke and orange.
Do you consider an apple a fruit?
No.
Why not?
I don't know.
I know it's super obvious,
but I just never made the connection that it would be soda.
If you said that on a first date,
I there would be no second date.
That'd be like,
this is the fucking Bimbo.
Jesus.
I thought I was dumb.
Yeah,
that's okay.
I can look.
That reminds you that.
That's why.
That's a story of the pockets.
That girl one time like,
hey,
you want to go out and you want to go grab some Sushi or something some night?
Oh my God,
I love Sushi.
But one time I ate it every day for like a month.
And what do you call the white party?
Or I am like,
ah,
the white party,
your eye.
She goes,
yeah,
it turned all yellow.
And I was like,
Hey,
bitch had jaundice.
Yes.
And I conveniently had another call coming in that I had to take.
Um,
well,
but even if you thought it was a bimbo,
I still try to go out with it still means like you are attracted to me.
I still tried to go out with her though.
She was an underwear model.
She modeled me undies,
me undies though.
She did.
Um,
so anyway,
uh,
pizza,
sorry to interrupt.
Okay.
Uh,
additionally,
okay.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
This came up.
So the guy was excited.
Where am I suspect the real situations.
My girlfriend has an image of who her partner is and saw potential in me meeting
that image someday.
But right now I'm not living up to that image.
It's like she's an NFL GM and I am the potential franchise quarterback who still
needs to work on his arm strength before becoming the starter in her eyes,
boozing it up like Johnny football instead of hitting the gym.
Um,
I gotta tell you some dude,
I'd let this girl go and I have to say something to do not fall in love with
potential and is a trap.
No,
no.
She,
well she's,
she's phone.
That's what I'm saying is for her to like fall in love with his potential is not
a good idea.
So it's really about,
that's the end of the question.
Yeah.
He kind of knocked it off too.
I know.
I gotta be honest with you.
I actually thought this guy was going to do better with the question.
I believe in his potential for this question,
but I didn't go nowhere.
She your grow,
I think you grow couch.
Oh,
I was gonna say,
I think you grow from making a point here.
Yeah.
So clearly it's not about the pizza.
It's about like the bigger picture for him and where he's at in her life and
she's not,
she's like,
she's a spoiled Brat who just got a job gifted to her so she doesn't understand
why she's still like good at it though.
Right?
Like it's,
it's not as if she just got it and she sucks at it.
I know,
but you know something he didn't,
he didn't say that he brought that up cause I would have brought that up still.
And what I'm saying,
I'm sorry,
I don't fucking come from the Goddamn Walden's.
What are the,
who's a big lawyer family on TV with a Waltons lawyers.
Cliff Huxtable was,
did you ever watch the wall?
No.
Sorry,
Claire House.
The Waltons was the Cosby show for white people.
What is the Waltons,
it's just a bunch of fucking rednecks.
Living in an old farmhouse is like 90 of them.
They all have fucking overalls.
Sounds terrible.
What do you have against white people and overall fucking dilapidated buildings?
Can I jump boy?
Yeah.
Didn't I do whoever good nights.
Good,
good,
good night.
Mary sue.
All right.
Barbara Jo.
Goodnight.
John Boy.
John boy who was John Boy.
John boy was like the fucking oldest dude on,
he was like a man.
He was like a young man,
but he was a boy.
John Boy.
It's his dad John Too.
And he's John Man.
He's John Man.
It's job.
We're not answering this guy's question.
I is the question.
There is no question but I think he just wants me to comment on the situation.
I have no idea,
but I would just say that,
um,
I would like bitch,
why don't you support me when I'm down.
How about you?
How about your potential to be a loving and supportive spouse?
Like why are you kicking me when I'm down?
Like don't you think that I'm trying to make it happen?
Don't you think I want to impress you.
Don't you think I want to be like,
you know the man that like you know is,
is everything that you've ever dreamed of.
I'm having a hard time right now.
Like you know that fucking four hour debate when you could just break up with
somebody.
I see too many red flags here.
Too many fucking red flags there.
First of all,
they're both lawyers.
Okay.
You can argue it out all night long since they're going to be competitive there
were in the same fucking field.
Then is boasting.
Then she gets fucking pregnant and like who the fuck puts their fucking practice
on hold?
You know you would have to obviously if she's carrying a baby,
like that's Kinda how it goes.
Yeah.
Like she should be loving.
So she's like,
so get your shit together.
Because eventually when we have a family,
I'm going to have to take time off.
Fuck debts.
She,
she seems like the Alpha male here in this and I think that she's going to want
to keep working and then this guy can,
this guy can just fucking chill out with the kids teaching tennis.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's not like he doesn't have a job.
He's looking for a job.
He almost got one.
Okay,
well keep at it.
Keep your chin up.
I Dunno both of these people's on annoying.
Why?
How is he annoying?
Both annoying.
He's like,
I'm playing tennis,
I'm doing my best.
And she's like,
get it to,
he's teaching tennis,
whatever.
He's trying and he's making money.
Yeah.
But she had to play it to teach it.
Ooh.
You're like killing in your own head right now.
I don't know what's going on with you.
You find yourself very amusing.
All right.
Right.
You know something.
All right.
I almost started crying like that guy's fucking PR potential.
Fucking wife,
his wife.
Um,
all right.
That is the podcast.
I don't know if I helped anybody.
I don't even know when I talked about,
I want to thank everybody who came out in Albuquerque and people who came in
Tucson,
Arizona.
It fucking Dean del Rey.
Jesus Christ has been fucking murderer and in front of me.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
Like people is like an audible like no.
And he's one his fucking sets over to knowing he's making me work out there.
He's crushing it.
A Dean's the best.
Uh,
and I will be with Dean next Sunday night and Santa fucking Barbara said,
I want to go and go out and spend the money that you're earning and go look at
stuff.
Fuck you.
Fuck you and has nothing to do.
And what do you want to do in Santa Barbara?
I want to go and hang out and see Santa Barbara is and how much does that cost?
It doesn't cost anything for me to like see cause I'm paying for it.
Paying for what exactly the trip to Santa Barbara.
You are working in Santa Barbara and I'm tagging along with you like what is the
problem and you just don't want,
you don't want me to cramp your style.
What do you and dean going to go?
Go Do's like skipping to the vineyards together and I go to a fucking brothel.
What do you think we're going to do?
Well again,
you're going to be there and be like,
oop,
you wear a condom.
I don't need that shit.
Listen,
if you can try to with that fucking second grade manipulation to try to turn the
conversation into that goddamn direction.
I'm just going to stare into it.
Nia,
why wouldn't I be able to come to Santa Barbara?
It's a beautiful place.
I haven't been there in years like what is the problem?
I'll tell you what the problem is because fuck you.
Fuck me.
Why?
Because you only see cause you only support me when I go to fun places.
You're never there when I need you.
When I go to,
when I got to Sacramento,
you never want to tag along.
I would potentially go to Sacramento.
I mean it is the capital of what?
Why would I go to a not fun city?
Like why would I do that?
Why would I need you to come along to a fun city?
I'm already having fun.
You love when I come on the row with you.
That's why I traveled so much with you before us and he had,
these are things I say to keep the relationship going fronting on your podcast
like I that you don't enjoy me being there with you and you're on the road
[inaudible] the road.
Who is you ooze a baby like you're so and your sewing,
controlling your just like the man of the family.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Love when I'm there with you on the road.
So knock it off.
Timeout.
You're talking a lot of shit.
I didn't get lonely on the road like this until I had a daughter.
Oh my God.
Are you,
are you see when I did a three week fucking run,
are you suggesting that you were not lonely on the road before we had a
daughter?
Are you saying for the most part,
yeah.
You didn't miss me when you're on the road for the most part,
yes.
So,
oh,
so then who are you lying to you?
You so you feel better.
That's completely untrue.
Have you ever seen what I do on the road?
I go to steams.
I go to games,
I'm hanging out with my friends.
I'm riding on a bus.
It's fucking tremendous.
The whole game thing is you got to make your wife feel like you're not having a
good time out there.
She's going to get upset.
Are you serious?
A lot of the times,
yeah.
Why?
No,
but now that,
now that I have a kid,
it's different.
So you,
so you never miss me when you were on the road,
all those nights as you called me and said you were lonely.
It was,
I was here and you saw something funny and you're sending me a lot of those
times which just all day and text messages all day like I miss you,
check this out.
Isn't this funny,
blah,
blah blah.
And like you,
that was a lot of those times.
A lot of the times it's bullshit.
Almost 15 years.
It's all been bullshit.
Not all,
but a lot of it is bullshit and I'm fully,
yeah,
that's how you do the road as a guy.
I don't believe you.
I will never trust you again.
If this is true.
You got to say it.
I'm going to Milwaukee.
I'm seeing the Henry Winkler statue.
I'm going Fonzie,
I'm going to the fucking the Harley Davidson Museum.
They have a statue of him.
Why?
What did he do?
Cause happy days was filmed in front of a live audience to the audience there.
But it's Oregon's rocky.
And do they really have a statue of him?
Yeah.
Seems like a waste of a statue.
Okay.
It's like the funniest thing ever.
Oh,
waste of a statue.
The statue could have been something else.
So what are you going to chop the head off and put fucking Merv Griffin's head
on there?
Wait a minute.
Is that character that iconic that it deserves its own statue.
A that guy.
That's why I love Bill Waukee.
That's why I love Milwaukee.
That's why I love Milwaukee's cause it's,
it's a city.
But it's small town.
Oh my God.
Milwaukee,
you got to do better.
Oh,
Nia.
So me,
that's one of my favorite fucking cities.
Okay.
I love Milwaukee.
Milwaukee.
You're okay with me?
All right.
Yeah,
this is the,
of course I miss you on the road.
I love you.
I love our daughter.
But this,
there's times where I'm really having a good fucking time out there.
So you have to text.
Hey honey,
I'm thinking about you.
I'm not thinking about you.
I'm,
I'm watching an SCC football.
I,
I sometimes forget I'm married when I'm at those games.
I get it.
You don't have to keep like,
you know,
don't because you went so hard the other way.
Go the
like,
I was so fucking pansy.
Yeah.
You were like,
you love me,
you miss me now I get it.
So it was self serving.
Obviously you're having fun on the road,
like you and you know,
text me pictures of you and Paul Versey and Joe Barton.
Nick like arm's length,
you know,
skipping into an arena of some sort.
Like,
so I get it.
I understand.
That's our tradition.
We always skipping
your breath.
Yeah.
I fucking ran a helicopter.
I fly myself to Vegas.
It's fucking,
it's a good time.
It's a good God damn time.
All right.
This podcast is way too fucking long.
It's an hour and a half long run,
right?
I okay.
Can we apologize to till the city of Milwaukee?
I will on behalf before we start a social media controversy here.
All right.
I'm done with this shit.
Uh,
that's it.
Everybody.
Happy Holidays,
man.
Happy Kwanzaa.
Happy Hanukkah.
Merry Christmas.
All that shit's coming up.
Uh,
go fuck yourselves and I'll talk to you on Thursday.
Stupid.